to CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is with us now
this homeland security adviser to
President George W Bush he helped create
the administration's strategy to handle
a potential flu pandemic Fran good
morning to you maybe you can sort all
some of this out for us because the CD
set CDC says the spread is inevitable
the president says it's not inevitable
what do you make of the mixed messages
coming from the White House because
everybody agrees it is a public health
emergency it's certainly a public health
emergency I think the president is
trying to be reassuring to the American
public I think people are understandably
frightened and concerned I think a CDC
is also trying to prepare people I think
the answer is somewhere in the middle
right I don't think it's helpful though
to get two different messages when
something is so scary don't people I
agree with you Kayla I think the right
answer here is that we're likely to see
more cases reported right we as we said
this morning there's about 50 here in
the United States as you heard from the
doctor at UC Davis he expects that there
are more here in the United States that
haven't been reported yet that will be
reported look we don't know where the
woman in California was infected it's
likely what people haven't talked about
is people can be totally asymptomatic
that is you can be infected with the
corona virus and have no symptoms and
that means you can infect others not
even know you have it and so that may be
part of the answer to this woman and
this woman our man in California friend
how does the corona virus compare to the
flu pandemic that you prepared for
during the Bush administration so to
give you a sense Tony that sorry Anthony
the flu has a morbidity rate a death
rate on an average of 0.1% a really bad
flu is a point five percent death rate
this right now we believe is a two
percent death rate right so it's much
worse we don't know if that's right
because we don't know if there are more
cases out there than we realize and so
it remains to be seen but that's part of
what makes this so dangerous and so
that's why public health officials we've
declared that they've declared the
emergency because they want to get
they're trying to get ahead of this and
in preparation from what you've seen so
far is the trumpet
in doing enough to control an outbreak
you know the federal government I think
we have to understand the federal
government really supports and got to
get the preparations right for the local
response right part of the reason you
appoint Patton's who is a governor to
oversee the response is because in the
end governors and mayors are the people
on the front lines of this who are going
to have to do it and so you see in the
budget requests for example they're
looking for masks and ventilators
they're looking to get the sort of
equipment that public health workers are
gonna be on the frontlines here are
gonna need because those are the people
who are gonna have to man the risk our
city of people sitting here watching you
today what's your best advice should we
fly not fly wear a mask not wear a mask
what are the resources where do we go to
get the answers so first and foremost
listen to dr. Tony Fauci who's advised
Republican and Democratic presidents on
infectious disease for 40 years I would
go to the CDC website if you're track if
you see it's a travel three warning
country don't go right now that's China
and South Korea if it's a travel -
warning country defer any non-essential
travel so look at the CDC website
curious about traveling in the United
States so you want to look at there
there are no travel restrictions here in
the United States but you do want to
look at where that where are the nodes
of outbreaks right and do you need to
travel to those places where are those
infections infections and you know it
never hurts washing your hands with warm
water and soap 20 seconds get your flu
shot that's right because if you get flu
shot and then you get symptoms at least
you're gonna help the doctors rule out
what it's not alright Fran Townsend
thanks so much good to see you